thank you so much for the introduction
and welcome everyone good afternoon let
me know if you have a tendency to move
while I talk so if you can't hear me at
some point just let me know so like you
heard I work primarily in machine
learning for healthcare and NLP at
nuance and I'm here to give you sort of
a bird's-eye view of this brand new
hot-off-the-press
library for NLP deep learning work
called P 1 NLP just a quick show of
hands how many of you have ever heard of
Apache MX net framework just heard of it
you should okay anyone was actually used
it anyone who works at Amazon for
example okay
yeah so I asked that because uh MX net
is what glue on an LP is based off of
and it's it's sort of a collaboration
between Amazon and Microsoft among among
other institutions and if you work at
Amazon it's very likely you've come
across it so what is v1 and uh P IMAX
net that you see right there is a
scalable open source deep learning
framework it's and and gluon is sort of
the imperative API to it and the gluon
NLP part of it is the high level API
focused on natural language processing a
corresponding layer to it is glue on CD
for example so if you're interested in
computer vision instead that is what you
would use the idea is to provide very
high level level API tasks for common
NLP tasks and there are plenty of other
language bindings available if you were
at the morning session today at the
keynote and if Kathryn managed to
convert to you there is for example a
Julia gulia API available to but by far
the Python interface is the most most
common one so why do we need yet another
framework because clearly we don't have
enough of those
right so there is there is constant talk
of how much fragmentation there already
is there are all these famous frameworks
that you've already heard of who wants
to learn yet another one the good part
is that at least the Python our binding
of this should look very very intuitive
and familiar so if you try and get your
hands dirty with this you'll realize
that this is not so much about this
won't feel so much like learning a new
thing altogether but being able to do
what you always do in NLP use cases but
with a lot more ease and flexibility so
a major motivation for this framework
was reproducibility and reproducing
state-of-the-art results in NLP has been
notoriously hard data processing is if I
dare say especially messy for NLP and
textual mode data the sort of benchmarks
that are released ever so often are
based on based on data which is which is
inherently messy which is noisy which is
which is hard to clean and the the whole
range of tasks that NLP use cases often
offer are are a big huge mess so if
you've ever tried to reproduce results
those fabulous results at Google and
Facebook come up with good luck with
that trying to do with custom confidence
so especially in the language domain
there are there are lots of typical
problems that you see in data handling
there are formatting errors Unicode
formatting is a well-known pain
languages just by their nature follow
very different grammatical and
syntactical rules and they represent
representations differ from language to
language a very simple example languages
being read from left to right versus
right to left the data representation of
a
is it's just naturally different input
padding is a is a reality in just about
every use case that you can think of and
data handling is an unglamorous problem
nobody wants to do the exactly up you
want nice and clean data to be handed
over to you so that you can spend all
your time doing fancy modeling and that
is what that is what the aim here is so
that allows you fast prototyping where
we not only try to hand over clean data
to you but also a whole bunch of
pre-trained models because it's well
it's one thing to try and implement and
learn about NLP by getting your hands
dirty with toy example the real fun
stuff is really complicated
and getting more and more so with time
so every time every every time a new
state-of-the-art benchmark is released -
first of all the complexity of it aside
the truth of the matter is that most of
us simply do not have the kind of
resources that go into generating these
models up to the level of quality that
the results are need for example if any
of you are like hands on an LP people
you probably heard of this brand-new
model that Google released called birds
and so birds took about 700 to 900 days
to train on the Google TPU cloud so
there is there is a huge value in being
able to get pre trained models for the
purpose of inference and sometimes it's
simply beyond beyond us to start from
scratch so a design principle on an LP
sort of adheres to is to have high-level
abstractions along with the you know
low level constructs like matrix
factorization so while you do have the
ability to code a matrix factorization
method if you want to the basic units in
NLP which are commonplace in deep
learning now like things like you know
if you want to do in batch normalization
while it might not be complicated to do
so it's sort of unnecessary to reinvent
the wheel because it's sort of a
standard procedure and all you should
really need to do is called bash norm
and again you know a call back to
Katherine stock this morning one thing I
learned to point out from her today was
that every time we say that X can do
something that shouldn't be construed as
saying that X is the only one that can
do something so while a lot of these
things are easy to do in below on an LP
that is by no means to say that it's
exclusive Lee available only in this
library so this is a high level API view
of glue on and these are the basic
building blocks of the NLP world here
and we look at some of the end-to-end
examples but data vocabulary embedding
modeling loss and initializations for
initially they sure module for the
models the data API mostly so this is
this is going back to the problem of the
unglamorous part of deep learning is
that the primary aim here is to make
data processing data pre-processing
efficient so you need huge amounts of
data to train a neural networks and the
aim here is to provide useful
abstractions to get textual data in
exactly the form and shape required to
train the deep learning models one thing
I would like to specifically point out
here is is the point about mini batching
and sampling that we'll talk about at
spawn briefly soon
one place that Leona nappy shines is
that a lot of effort has gone into
providing a number of popular benchmark
date sets out of the books so you
basically need to literally just call
these my names without having to worry
about doing any pre-processing any
clean-up on it and using your own models
or using any of the pre trained models
it is really simple out-of-the-box to
run an end-to-end in that method so this
is by no means an exhaustive list but
for example the Google one-billion no
word levels formats is the standard for
all language modeling tasks the analogy
and the analogy test sets are the
benchmark for evaluating all kinds of
word embeddings wikitext ooh 103 they
are basically just various versions of
the Wikipedia word level dataset
similarly all of these are machine
translation benchmarks caught right
there at the end is is the benchmark
associated with the state-of-the-art
question answering system from Stanford
also known as reading comprehension and
that link there basically will give you
the list of all all popular benchmarks
available so going back to data batching
jus trainer models it's not sufficient
to just have the data it must both be in
a right format and efficiently arranged
for computation so this usually means
that in the neural network world you
need to group the data together in
batches so that it can be processed in
parallel and getting the best use out of
the available resources mostly mostly
GPUs so for efficient training you need
to transform the input data into what we
call mini batches and consider a model
that takes independent sentences as
input so this part is the is the simple
simple transformation of the input data
and in any kind of data set that you can
imagine it's very
unlikely to have inputs of standard
constant length so your sentences in
every data set therefore if your units
are paragraphs their lands differ
documental in stiffer at whatever
granularity you talk about the input
units are almost always of different
sizes for example this is the first
hundred paragraphs from the wiki test
texts to data said that we talked about
and this is the distribution of what how
their lengths vary now what this means
is that data padding comes into play in
a way that you need to basically make
sure each of your batches is of a
constant size and to do that you add
each of the smaller inputs to make it to
the maximum input length normally this
is left up to the user adding a bit to
its to his or her cognitive load and
your input samples when they are very
length the padding has to be made to
maximum length and with no bucketing
will come will come to what how this is
actually done in clone NLP in a second
but in the absence of any sort of
bucketing if you simply just divide your
data at random or in Cyrille order
whatever the average padding for each of
these mini batches is about eleven point
seven this is the number for the wiki
text to distribution that we just saw
and what this means is this makes data
loading slow because there is a there's
an inherent memory inefficiency here and
the mini batching is basically related
to parameter updates so this is a this
is this is a fairly common operation and
a frequent one what blue on an LP
provides out of the box is something
called sorted bucketing so instead of
just creating random buckets and letting
the you know padding do its thing poor
bucket you divide it into n sample each
and then
sort or all of each all of these buckets
and that way your padding basically
looks like this so you're trying to
basically group similar length sentences
together so each of your mini batch
level padding becomes less and less
which basically just makes your loading
much much more efficient now average
padding in this case if you see right
there is 3.7 as opposed to 11.7 in the
previous case so this is something that
is straight out of the sampler class in
groanin LP and this literally has
technically no coding involved coming to
the model API in any NLP task or any any
statistical modeling tasks in general
this is broadly the standard flow you
gather data you build your model you
train the model over the data you
evaluate it and you infer on unseen data
this is a very very broad view a lot of
these tips might be iterative and this
is just to outline how let's say our
typical use case would look like we look
at one right away so one of the most
basic NLP tasks is what we call language
modeling and we will just look at what
it takes to create a language basically
to use a language model in in England
okay so a statistical model is simply a
probability distribution it's over
sequences of words or characters we will
really look at the word level language
modeling here and what this gives you an
answer to is which which among the
following strings that you're about to
encounter is more likely to appear
appear in the language so a perfectly
grammatical sentence will have a high
probability of occurrence while
incoherent babble of words put together
even if it might be grammatical will
have a very low probability of
occurrence in a particular language
model
so it basically tries to assign precise
probabilities to each string string of
words so what that means is that given
sequence of words the job of the
language model is to predict the next
one that's at every every time step in
the neural network world
this is broadly what the structure might
look like you have input words which map
to input and bearings again if you've
worked with NLP you're probably aware of
where to wax or deform Eddings or globe
embeddings or fast text more recently
and then the hidden state layer here is
what is where the magic lies so this
this could basically be any kind of deep
learning model that we talked about for
language modeling the most common one
known to be used these days is what we
called RNAs and one of the more common
examples in blue on NLP is is the LS TM
model which is the long short term
memory model which is a specific kind of
RNA model available so this is pretty
much what it looks like to generate a
language model in v1 NLP this is the
basic set up all of it very familiar
standard imparative Python code this
basically sets up the context if you
want to if you have GPUs available by
all means go ahead use them if not you
can fall back on the cpu set up here
this is how you set hyper parameters we
will see how they are used in the
training call much later if all of these
variables should be my large quite
familiar this is a bad size the learning
rate the number of epochs that is
probably too low except for demo
purposes the BP TT is the is the back
propagation through time parameter used
for used in the batter file
that we'll just see and the green
clipping numbers again if you're
wondering how do you know how to set
these numbers that is where the black
magic of deep learning is to be honest
and each of these parameters literally
is is a paper each and still with no
good answers so these these numbers if
you're wondering are largely empirical
and come from experience so to speak so
this is how we can load a dataset
extract the vocabulary numerical eyes
and batch of five for the truncated back
propagation through time method this is
the wiki text to dataset that's being
loaded here and the partitioning into
train validation and test systems the
the PPT T thing is not something that
you want to get hung over it basically
just transforms the data set the corpus
BBT batch of five method it transforms
that it is set into batches of numerical
eyes samples and in a way that the
record sets basically from the last
batch connect to the current batch for
each sample so and then there are a
whole bunch of arguments associated with
that and this is how you can load a
predefined
two-layer Alice TM language modeled with
with the tied embeddings and the output
weights so the function call is
literally just this and if you print the
model and the vocabulary details this
basically tells you what is the model
that you're getting this is basically
telling you about the embeddings and the
hidden dimensions are to about 200 and
the dataset name on which the pre
trained model is trained the specified
then you will get the returned
vocabulary from the training set of the
dataset and the dropout values the
embedding dimensions and and the whole
nine yards this is where use this is how
you set the parameters for
the trainer this is where we utilize the
value of the learning rate that we said
earlier and we specify our loss function
which is the standard soft mass for the
softmax cross-entropy and this is what
it takes to Train the existing model our
loss function here is the cross entropy
loss used for the multi-class
classification and in this case we'll
back propagate for 35 time steps which
is the value we set for P P DT right
right at the start updating our weights
for bias GT which we specified here and
a learning rate of 20 that was one line
of training and this is one line of
evaluation this is where the test loss
comes from and the evaluate method
basically returns the test loss and that
is where we get calculate the perplexity
from the perplexity is the standard way
of evaluating how good your language
model is essentially minimizing
perplexity is it can be seen as
maximizing the probability so less
perplexity makes for a better model so
in this case for example the wikitext
two system that was loaded has a chest
perplexity of about 170 point four nine
which is such a fairly good empirically
speaking so so this is this was
basically about 20 lines of code to get
the state-of-the-art lsdm language model
on the other side of the spectrum is is
another NLP task which is which has been
considered the holy grail of vanellope
for a long time which is machine
translation September 2016 is when
Google set up the system called the
neural machine translation which is the
GMT system now and they replace their
previous statistical method with with
this after about 10 years and this at
this point supports about hundred
languages language pairs
and this is pretty much the first time
where this level of transfer learning
was successful where we could see zero
shot translations being made which
essentially means that even if you
trained your system to translate between
say Japanese and English and Korean and
English your system was learning how to
translate between Japanese and Korean as
well so this this was pretty much never
done before and this is the data from
the side by side evaluation that Google
had released so the neural gen geometry
system comes fairly close to the human
system for a lot of language pairs this
is the architecture that was utilized to
generate this state of the art system
what this is showing you right now is an
encoder decoder architecture the MIT the
network here is basically encoding the
source words as a list of vectors where
each of the vectors is the meaning of
the words that it has encountered so far
and once an entire sentence is read the
English sentence the sort the target
language is generated one one word at a
time
and the decoder basically pays attention
to the weighted distribution of off of
the searchers so the details of this
architecture aside the point of putting
this diagram here is to basically just
get a consensus that this network is
frickin complex and if you wanted to
reproduce these numbers or you know
generate this model so to speak would be
would be hard would be complicated would
be error-prone and again the point about
how much resource is actually going to
generating as to a state of the art
model so a model like this is available
out of the box so this is literally all
that is required to do construct the GN
MT system you can call the
encoder and decoder by the GMT encoder
decoder and with with the with the
parameters that you that either come by
default or again this is this is
available for tuning and then you can
feed the decoder in the encoder to the
nmt model to construct precisely the
model that really saw the Google model
is also open source and it's a tensor
flow models which means that their
numbers are available and available for
a reproduction as well and the gluon LP
team did reproduce those numbers and
this is the blues code that they have on
that so blue score is the standard way
of measuring translation systems and
this is the standard numbers that dual
released and these are the numbers that
go on it I hope he has with pretty much
similar similar parameters a huge
improvement on this was in 2017 which is
the famous transformer system where
again without going into too much detail
of the architecture itself still a
fairly complicated architecture the
point of this was to demonstrate that
you probably don't even need L STM's
what you really need is the is a
standard feed-forward network and the
key is really in attention this the
paper that this came from is literally
called attention is all you need and
again point being still a fairly
complicated system to generate from
scratch again available right out of the
box and these are the numbers you know
in comparison with the tensorflow
implementation of the same thing this is
an English to German translation system
again it's it's it publicly available
and included in the library I do want to
go back for a second to the GMT system
and point out this particular line where
it says model dot hybridize and I want
to dwell upon that for just a second so
the hybrid is part of this
to to basically talk about what
hybridize is doing there
is to is to draw your attention to the
difference between the deep learning
programming paradigms between the
different frameworks for example so
again this is not a very watertight kind
of demarcation but by and large very
broadly speaking there are decorative
frameworks and then there are imperative
frameworks in in the in the ecosystem at
the moment so with the declarative
frameworks or what we call the symbolic
frameworks as well
these are tensor flow for example piano
is another one they what you end up
doing there is it's a declare a fixed
computational graph is to construct a
fixed computational graph first and then
execute it end to end now once your
computational graph is fixed that
basically means it's it's portable it
runs more efficiently it can be
pre-loaded and what that also means is
that you are trading off some
flexibility because you can't really you
can you can't really encode any special
logic in there like you can in say an
imperative system like like numpy for
example very very simply speaking so
while it's it also it also makes a
pre-loaded computational graph much
harder to debug because it's it's hard
to manipulate anything that's going on
in the intermediate states of that but
but because of its efficiency
tensorflow Tiano some of the big
frameworks in the space are actually
iterative in nature the imperative
frameworks on the other hand are also
well represented by some other big
frameworks
I torch chainer for example and alone an
LP at the moment they are they are just
just the opposite they execute commands
one by one just like you would expect in
your in in the normal Python control
flow for example what you see numpy or
in or in MATLAB for example it's it's
everything that the symbolic systems are
not it's it's slightly easier to debug
it's slightly easier to interrupt and
inspect it's more flexible but at the
same time it makes it less efficient for
precisely the same reasons now what what
glown NLP tries to do here is to
hybridize it tries to get a hybrid
execution so the block construct in a
note in blue one is basically a base
class for all kinds of models that you
that you create the sequential construct
is is sort of the basic neural network
layer object so it stores a chain of
neural network layers that execute in
turn where the output from the previous
layer feeds it becomes the input of the
next layer so everything like this for
example would be a would be a sequential
object or or something like this where
where you see neural network layer
stacked on top of each other
it is basically an implementation of
sequential love there now the sequential
construct is basically right here the
sequential construct is is is the base
class for this and to be able to create
a hybrid symbolic and impurity system
what we want to know P does is it it
implements a hybrid block and a hybrid
sequential class so the idea behind that
is to one second
is when you call the hybridize method on
a model what it is trying to do is to
basically allow for creating symbolic
graphs in the sense that it is going to
make imperative calls but after the
activation the first hybrid forward call
that you make the symbolic graph is
basically cached so it gives you the
ability to get the efficiency associated
with loading of with pre loading an
existing computational graph so the next
time you're making you're making a
forward call with within the neural
network it is not going to make an
explicit function call but it is just
going to preload the cache to cache
computational graph so it sort of gives
you you know the flexibility of the
imperative paradigm as well as tries to
utilize the efficiency associated with
the symbolic paradigm as well so by
default if by default within MX net
everything that's pre-designed
is in terms of hybrid sequential so if
you basically went back and inspected
then empty model here you would see that
it would be it would be constructed out
of hybrid sequence should locks and not
just sequential blocks so which which
essentially also means that if you're if
you're creating a neural network of only
emits net layers you don't really have
to worry about this optimization and it
comes built-in which is sort of a nice
segue to the last point and trying to
make that if you are for any reason
really really invested into one of these
paradigms that I really love PI torch
don't make me move to learn NLP there is
a way to not fight and peacefully
coexist which is or in an X
and omx is the open neural network
exchange format and it's an open format
to represent deep learning models it's a
sort of an intermediate representation
which supports all of these pretty
well-known frameworks and it's easier to
move models and convert them from one
framework to another and this is right
now in the MX net contradicts package
and the the format supports MX net in
one direction right now which means that
if you have a model created in say PI
torch or any of the any of the framework
that supports it's easy to import it
into intimate annex net gluon directly
and it can be used with the optimized
inference engine within MX net even if
your uh model was not trained within the
same framework the opposite direction is
not available right now so you can't
really export in a mixin net model right
now but I saw at least one place where
it says that it's in the works and might
be coming soon so this is this is this
basically just increases the flexibility
of you of using models that might not be
available in MX net world or in view on
an LP right away or if some if there is
something if you've created a model
which is you know really high performing
but it's all written in PI torus you
don't really have to sit and rewrite it
in one NOP it can be directly imported
due to the Konex support these are there
references the best known references for
grown NLP they do have a couple of
forums as well I think the existing
forum is probably all in Chinese and the
English help forums have sort of moved
by consensus to stack overflow so but
the stack overflow support is amazing
for igloo and loopy on the the github
repository is obviously useful the
documentation if you do check it out
notice the section where it says an
example scripts so it not only provides
pre train models for you to load there
are full end-to-end examples for a whole
range of NLP tasks the sentiment
analysis translation which is which are
all which which basically need a lot of
building blocks to come together but
there are a whole range of example
scripts available that are easy to run
straight out the box that's pretty much
it and we're happy to take questions I'm
if you find me outside in the hallway
ask me what I did with this which is not
much at the moment this is really really
new but I have tried my hand at using
the existing use cases and the only
trouble is that a lot of these are
heavily GPU dependent so you can you can
see how how they work end to end pretty
much in in a local environment local CPU
driven environment as well to see the
actual numbers that they report
unfortunately you will probably need a
GPU environment thank you thank you
thing does anybody have any questions
you can take like one or two you
mentioned that had some ways of helping
you get things in the right format does
that include like for a given model to
have like a text normalization pipeline
that gears it towards like the same that
they used for training that particular
model because I've heard that that can
be you know very impactful to make sure
you're normalizing the text in the same
way that however you know the model is
trained as Jim so do you mean the the
pre-existing data sets an e in it are
they normalized for use out of the box
or do you mean you want to know that
yeah for new data that you bring in yes
so there is a the data pipeline API in
general it
has what I'd suggest is look up what's
the datastream abstractions are so there
there are a whole range of data stream
abstractions which basically just let
you sequentially call transform methods
on it so you can essentially just load
any kind of data and run successive
called successive transform methods on
it great things alright thank you so
much Neha